SEAN ROBINSON: So
the technical staff
consists of myself
and two more people.
Our job is to maintain
all the equipment,
develop new experiments.
In practice, we also
end up teaching a lot.
Something that's very
common is a student
is struggling with
an experiment.
They don't quite understand how
their measurement is working.
They've worked with
the section leader.
They've worked with the grad
TA in trying to figure it out.
And at some point, they
really just believe
the experiment is just broken.
That's the point in which we
call in the technical staff,
and we figure out.
And more often than
not, it's not broken.
It's just working with
the apparatus is actually
just very confusing.
There are lots of degrees of
freedom in operating any given
piece of apparatus.
And it's oftentimes
the technical staff
who know more about what's
happening in the apparatus
and getting them to give
good data than sometimes some
of the other people.
Just because we're here
in every single section.